the three dumbest things people spend  their money on  number one is high-priced coffee that's  insane particularly when you have debt  to be paying for two and three dollars  for coffee  that actually cost you fifteen cents to  make it's just sheer stupidity number  two people buy too many clothes people  fall in love with clothes they see on  the shelf somewhere in a store buy it  never aware it's particularly true with  shoes ask yourself some time you open  the closet how many shoes you're  actually wearing under the dozens that  are sitting there  number three is they forget that money  can be either your most powerful ally or  your worst enemy debt is evil if you can  save money put it in the bank or invest  it and make interest you're way ahead of  being in debt debt bad you heard it here  first  you